Reality is that right now, it's a war of
attrition between the United States and
Iran. And the Iranians have been
preparing 20 years for this conflict.
And now they have a pretty good strategy
of how to weaken and ultimately destroy
the American empire.
We are teaching people how to pray. And
every time they pray, you get to share
in that reward. And when they teach
their children and their children's
children
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha every recitation for
just 100 pounds
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people.
>> Like me, learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. So, I came across a video of
Professor Young. I think that's how it's
pronounced. And he made three
predictions. He made three predictions
about the Iran war and how Iran is will
be winning this war. So, let's go
through those predictions, inshallah.
And then uh we're going to go to a video
from Political Alchemy uh alhamdulillah
um and watch those videos uh amazing
analysis of what is going on and how
Iran is actually winning this war and
they are going to win this war. So,
let's go to the first video of Professor
Young. You made three big predictions.
One,
that Trump would win.
Two, that he would start a war with
Iran. And three, that the US would lose
that war. It's quite a stunning
prediction. You know, do you stand by
it? Um the reality is that right now,
it's a war of attrition between the
United States and Iran. And the Iranians
have been preparing 20 years for this
conflict. Usually the downfall of many
empires, brothers and sisters, is this
um when they become really powerful and
they think they are untouchable. And
that is where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
even in the Quran, there's a verse in
the Quran where Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions that Allah will send
signs and signs
until the person, an individual, this
can be nations, yes,
Um avoid those signs and thinks that
they're untouchable. Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala says, "And when they're at their
peak, think they're untouchable, Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala snatches their soul."
So, America is acting like it's, you
know, can do whatever it likes, whenever
it likes. And this is the downfall of
many empires. So, 20 years they've been
a threat to Iran. Okay, and you guys
know my position with the whole Iran,
etc. uh thing. So, um and what the
Prophet is saying is very key here
because
they are now been preparing for this for
20 years. So, America's been thinking
they can do whatever they like, but Iran
has been preparing for this for 20
years. And you can see them attacking
multiple 20-plus countries with a
ballistic missile, Subhana Allah. But
let's carry on. And now they have a
pretty good strategy of how to weaken
and ultimately destroy the American
empire.
So, what uh
the Iranians are doing is they're waging
war against the entire global economy.
And so, they are striking the GCC
countries. They're going after the
critical energy infrastructure, they've
blocked out the Strait of Hormuz. And
eventually, they will go after the water
desalination plants, which is the
lifeblood of these nations. And not only
that, there is a massive uh there's
another video which I'll show you, uh
the airspace. There's like a massive
hole
on in the sky, basically, where planes
that have this having an effect on
global economy on a level. Oil prices
are going up. The Strait of Hormuz is
um blocked, okay? And uh Subhana Allah,
it's it's it's you can see they're using
strategy and they're being smart about
this. And that's why it's predicted that
Iran is going to win this war. And
that's going to be a massive blow to
America. Because they don't have fresh
water supply. The uh Iranians are
actually threatening
the very existence of Saudi Arabia, UAE,
uh Qatar. And what this is important is
that the Gulf states are really the
linchpin of the American economy. So,
what they do is they sell petrodollars
and then they recycle the petrodollars
back into the American economy through
the investments in the stock market. And
right now, we know that the entire
American economy is propped up by AI
investments in data centers. And a lot
of all that comes from the Gulf states.
So, if the Gulf states are no longer
able to sell oil, and they're no longer
able to finance AI this AI bubble in the
United States, then this AI AI bubble
will burst, and with it will
will burst as well as well as the entire
American economy, which is really a
financial Ponzi scheme. Yeah, I mean, to
your point, sir, and Amazon data And
that's key. They are selling petrol
dollars, and then they're using those
petrol dollars to invest back in
America.
I mean, look at that. You're you're
selling oil thinking you're making
profit, but then you're reinvesting that
back to America.
I mean, you're you're their puppet. They
can they can they can pull the plug on
you instantly. center was literally hit
in the UAE. Now, we also wanted to talk
to you about munition. The United States
is racing to accomplish Iran mission
before munitions run out.
>> States military is not designed to fight
a 21st century war. Remember the
military industrial complex came to
being after World War II, and it was
designed to fight the Cold War. And the
Cold War was really about muscle
flexing, who was the first get the
person on the moon. And so, the entire
American military strategy revolves
around very sophisticated technology
that costs a lot of money to
build, and that's what the
American air defense system is. And
that's why we're seeing this asymmetry
in this war, where you have these
million dollar missiles trying to take
out these 50,000 dollar drones, and it's
not sustainable
in the long term. And so, what we're
seeing is really the puncturing of the
aura of invincibility that sustained
American hegemony for the past 20 years.
Okay, so that's one video, and I'm going
to a second video of showing how this is
affecting the global economy when it
comes to flights being diverted. The
US-Iran war has now created a giant hole
in the sky, and we are going to pay the
price, literally. You see, if you open
Flightradar today, you'll see something
quite astonishing, a giant hole where
one of the world's busiest aviation
crossroads used to be. Several countries
have now entirely closed their
airspaces, causing thousands of
cancellations globally, major disruption
at airports, stranding thousands of
tourists across the Middle East, and
crucially, sharply increasing costs for
airlines who are now forced to take
longer, more congested, fuel-consuming
routes. And I wonder who's going to be
paying the price for that one. But, it's
not just a hole in the sky creating a
hole in your pocket. There's also now a
hole in the ocean, too. Because similar
to the airspace, there's now a giant gap
in the world's busiest oil shipping
lane. Not only is a staggering 20% of
the world's oil and gas shipped through
the Strait of Hormuz, but also 34% of
global fertilizer, large amounts of
methanol, pharmaceuticals, etc. And
yesterday, not only did Iran close the
lane, they actually vowed to attack any
ships trying to pass. As a result, the
price of oil and gas has sharply risen
and will continue to have wide rippling
effects as long as these holes exist. I
mean, some experts are predicting that
oil could reach $120 per barrel for the
first time in years. So, the most
important question is, how long? Well,
Trump revealed for the first time last
night that the US military expected the
war to last four to five weeks. But, he
did leave the door open saying,
>> But, whatever the time is, it's okay.
Whatever it takes.
>> most analysts predicted that the war in
Ukraine would be over in a matter of
weeks. Yet, four years later, they're
still fighting. I mean, the World Cup is
only four months away. Will Iran be
participating if they're at war with the
host nation? You see, Trump said, "We're
doing this not for now. We're doing this
for the future."
>> But, right now, the future is looking
pretty damn [music] expensive.
>> So, there you go. Subhanallah. It
reminds me and again, like I said
before, I'm not in Iran's side cuz Iran
has killed half a million Sunnis in
Syria. Yes? So, for those who hate
Zionists and Israel,
you have to be consistent. You have to
be morally consistent, not
strategically. You have to also hate
Iran's actions. Now, like I said before,
when it comes to theologically,
we are closer to the Iranian Shias,
should we say for that matter. Okay, I'm
not talking about the Rawafidha. Okay,
which we believe are Kuffar,
disbelievers, yeah? Who insult the
prophet's wives and Sahaba. I'm not
talking about them. Strategically, we
allow them and I'll be honest with you,
that's that's how it was, but they are
both they have committed atrocities both
with each other with each other. But,
you know, when it comes to Subhanallah,
Allah Subhanallah Ta'ala's soldiers,
taking them Listen out of this. When
Ibrahim Alayhis Salaam
was confronted with Nimrod, okay? Nimrod
Ibrahim Alayhis Salaam says in the Quran
that Allah can give life and take life.
He said, "I can do the same." He brought
two people. He said, "I'm going to let
him live and kill him." And Ibrahim
Alayhis Salaam said, "Okay, Allah brings
the sun from the east. Okay, make it
come from the west. Yeah?" And he knew
he couldn't because he was saying that.
And Allah Subhanallah Ta'ala sent a
insect. Yes? That went through his nose
into his brain. That so much so that
they say that he used to hit his head,
yes? Out of He went crazy. He lost his
mind.
And then Allah Subhanallah Ta'ala says
that Allah's soldiers and nobody knows
about Allah Subhanallah Ta'ala's
soldiers. This war seems that America's
spending trillions of dollars. This war
can This war can change. The war can
turn into something totally different
and all those expenditures that they
have Subhanallah is diminished in a
second. So,
it looks like Iran is winning this war.
It does seem like Subhanallah there's a
shift happening and this might be the
beginning of the end of the United
States of America or certainly Israel.
And Subhanallah brothers and sisters,
you can see Allah Subhanallah Ta'ala has
a plan. We look at it and we don't
understand what's going on. But, the
fact that Prophet Muhammad called out
three things and predicted it, it looks
like the third one is on its way that
Iran is going to be victorious.
I mean, that's all we can say inshallah.
Also, check out Political Alchemy
inshallah.
And his videos are absolutely amazing.
Brothers and sisters, you want to be up
to date with the political sphere,
what's going on geopolitically,
and brothers and sisters, that's all I
have to say, inshallah. Till next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. We are teaching people how
to pray. And every time they pray, you
get to share in that reward. And when
they teach their children, and their
children's children, [crying]
the reward continues. Every Fajr, Dhuhr,
Asr, Maghrib, Isha, every recitation,
for just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people.
>> Like me. Learn how to pray salah. Donate
today.